robert spencer as we have discussed the
new
president of iran who was hand-picked by
the current supreme leader
who was infamous around the world for
mass murders of
a tremendously disgusting proportion
may not only be president now but could
be next in line to be
the supreme leader oh my gosh would the
world be
in trouble is that really a possibility
it's a very real possibility barry as a
matter of fact it's a likelihood
that kamene's selection of riese as
president
heralds is essentially being anointed
heir apparent
kamene is 80 and he's not going to be
around forever
and so he has chosen someone who is
a very severe hardliner as a signal
to the domestic uh opponents
of the regime and to the world that
the islamic republic is going to be on
the
uh aggressive taking an aggressive
stance
and the rest of the world is going to
have to step back uh
this is what khamenei wants for iran
to be standing up to what he calls the
arrogant powers
and nobody more than rajisi is going to
do that